un petit pas de danse pour montrer sa
forme retrouvée dans le nevada donald
trump poursuit sa série frénétique de
meetings face à des partisans galvanisés
le président américain en a profité pour
vanter de nouveau sa guérison rapide du
coronavirus à la traîne dans les
sondages
il a aussi appelé à l'unité des
républicains après certaines critiques à
son encontre
donald trump a surtout repris ses
attaques virulentes contre son rival joe
biden si vous votez pour baden il vendra
vos emplois à la chine
il abandonnera votre futur aux mains du
virus il va mettre en place un
confinement
il écoutera les scientifiques moi si
j'avais écouté les scientifiques nous
aurions en ce moment même un pays en
pleine récession
au lieu d'être une fusée regardez
simplement les chiffre à près de 40 km
de là joe biden a choisi la caroline du
nord pour cimenter sa campagne dans une
ambiance beaucoup plus calme le
démocrate a dénoncé la gestion de la
pandémie par la maison blanche
il a également lancé un appel à
l'électorat afro américain en rendant
hommage à georges floyd tué par un
policier blanc fin mai à minneapolis
pensez à ce que ça suppose d'aimer ce
pays aujourd'hui en étant une personne
noire
c'est un amour profond pour ce pays
pendant trop longtemps il n'a pas été
reconnue nous avons besoin d'un
dirigeant qui fasse baisser les tensions
qui rétablisse les lignes de
communication et qui nous rassemblent
pour guérir et espérer en tant que
président c'est exactement ce que je
ferai le discours de joe biden semble
pour l'instant faire mouche
il mène de 9 points dans les sondages by
dane et surtout en avance dans les états
indécis qui peuvent faire basculer
l'élection
les deux candidats se retrouveront jeudi
prochain asheville pour leur dernier
débat présidentiel
[Musique]